[Music]
let's do this witches I'm your High
hostess Liana Galera and this is the
witches council et's spellbinding show
that's all about the chilling Adventures
of Sabrina
and today we're about to brew up some
behind-the-scenes secrets with some
serious
spoilers so if you have not watched
Sabrina episode 7 yet hit pause hop on
your broomstick and fly out of here
right away and you me together for
everyone else turn your spell books to
page 107 and listen closely because
there's a Riverdale crossover that we
need to discuss immediately so at the
end of episode 7 aka the one that was
all about the feast of feasts and might
be my favorite episode of the season
there was an epic Easter Egg that some
of you non Riverdale viewers might have
missed and that all of you Riverdale
lovers must have a ton of questions
about go on luckily i'm bewitching you
with exclusive answers from the
executive producer of both shows roberto
aguirre-sacasa and that'll be the
takeaway I ordered so when Miss Wardwell
was opening the door to get her
Thanksgiving feast
Riverdale fans saw a familiar face
delivering her pizza it was Ben Ben
she'll be right down
yes that's right the same Ben that we've
been seeing since season 1 of Riverdale
he was working at the twilight drivin
where are the dogs
he was also the same teen smooching on
miss Grundy the night she was murdered
and he's the same kid who was
interviewing super shady chick for a job
at the Bijou in fact I did an entire
episode devoted to this mysterious
reappearing character on my Riverdale
series sweet letter secrets now most
recently and most confusingly Ben was
seen in season 3 of Riverdale playing
Griffins and gargoyles with Dilton doily
before the two sacrificed themselves to
the gargoyle King although been
initially survived his first brush with
death in the season 3 premiere he then
gave Betty Jughead and audiences
everywhere a heart attack when he did
this in episode 302 fly to
so just how or when was been able to
show up on this world world's doorstep
especially because it really seemed like
she was about to eat him instead of the
pizza I can't tell you how starved I am
to get to the bottom of this I caught up
with the man was all the answers Roberto
aguirre-sacasa at the Sabrina red-carpet
premiere and asked him to summon up the
truth and when I asked if Ben's cameo in
Greendale was before or after he died in
episode 302 of Riverdale roberto
answered quote that's a good question
and that depends it suggests a very deep
deep mythology where time and space
bends I love that kid I'm sad that he
keeps churning up and horrible things
keep happening to him so does this mean
Ben could have survived that fall from
the hospital and he said it seemed like
it was pretty final but yet there he is
in Greendale
but in Greendale everyone pops up the
dead don't stay dead long in Greendale
um what what does this mean what do you
guys think did miss ward well spare
Ben's life did an afterlife version of
Ben end up in Greendale am i over
analyzing this crossover or are you all
just as confused as I am if you're nice
uh sure
tell me cast your spell in the comments
right now and bewitched me with your
thoughts and theories and if you had a
wicked fun time with me today please
give this video a like and then hit
subscribe so you never miss the
behind-the-scenes Sabrina scoop you can
only find on the witches Council now
thanks for summoning me and I'll see you
soon witches
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]